you mentioned earlier Jasmine you were
talking about how how to have a healthy
relationship and and how that works can
you can you explain how to have a
healthy relationship to my audience I
don't think it looks the same for
everyone but I think when there's mutual
respect Mutual support when the when
people are together because they
actually love each other um they're like
you know one thing manosphere says oh
when a woman you know makes more money
she's you know she's more likely to
leave yeah well those women probably
didn't want to be with you in the first
place um so I think and instead of
gaining status and money in order to
attract a woman who wants to use you for
status and money finding someone who has
similar values that you feel compatible
with and that has mutual respect and
love but what does that like that's
extremely abstract I mean talking about
mut like how do we put that into
practical terms mutual respect Mutual
support like how does that manifest
itself in reality maybe just deal with
one of them like like how do you
manifest mutual respect what does mutual
support look like support well I mean
like for instance find I think the first
thing you need to do if you're trying to
find someone is find someone who shares
your values so clearly like if me and Mr
Rich Cooper we would not spend two
seconds together Me Maybe you wouldn't
spend two seconds together find someone
who who has the same values as you I am
all for traditional religious people
going to church and finding someone
there I think they can end up being
completely happy there are people who
are in polyamorous liberal relationships
that are also entirely happy so find
someone who shares your values shares a
lot of your it doesn't have to be like
every single belief but has the same
kind of uh Foundation as you and then I
guess respecting each other in the sense
of finding what works for your
relationship and respecting each other's
boundaries I know it seems super what
does a man have to do to earn your
respect it
is what what does a man have to do to
earn your
respect um what does a man have to do to
earn my respect I guess showcase a lot
of the traits that I find respectable
like what um being being kind being
open-minded uh being intelligent I
respect intelligence um being helpful
being supportive like those kinds of
things I think are respectable traits
and I typically go for those kind that's
that's the exact same answer that every
woman always gives but it's not what
they actually respond to
though okay well what do they respond to
Rich because so far you wouldn't even
put up my stats that are actually
correct and you know I I I didn't know
that we were going to compare stats so I
didn't I didn't prepare stats what's not
comparing stats so when someone gets
divorced in the United States that's
recorded these are not difficult to find
it's recorded this isn't like a study
it's on an observation recorded
everywhere in the world it's recorded in
Canada too huh it's recorded everywhere
in the world it's recorded So it's very
easy to find so I don't know how you
would have gotten wrong stats what I
think you're doing is what fresh and fit
does where you're taking a selection
bias out of the couples that are already
getting divor I read studies what study
did you read then why can't you pull up
one and I can give you like 10 places
where this is recorded I'll be right
back hold on a second
okay so well well he's doing that I want
to get back to this because because yes
like I I think what we try to do on this
show on this channel and the stuff that
we talk about is we try to give guys
practical I only have one here right now
actually hold on and so saying things
like be supportive or find shared values
like they're very very in the abstract
they don't they don't have they don't
hold a lot of water they don't hold a
lot of meaning unless you can be very
very specific so that's what I'm kind of
looking for what are sort of these
specifics that we can tell people to do
well first of all I don't think your
audience wants to date women like us
anyway so it's really bizarre that you
come to us for advice but two I would
also say that um the first we're not a
matching agency Jasmine we're just
having a conversation with ladies no I
understand that but if you're if you're
here to give advice to men would your
advice to men be to date women like me
anyway no my advice to men is having on
endorsement of men dating
you yeah but then well all women are
different so what I say I like and the
advice I would give to men would be to
attract a woman like me so let's put
that disclaimer there if you guys want
my advice on how to attract women it's
going to be women like me how would you
rate yourself like between one and 10
like on a scale of one to 10 I think
that's a stupid Whimsical and
arbitrary I don't I don't you're
comparing yourself like women like me
like you're putting yourself in a
category so what category I I'm not
putting myself on a category where I'm
rating you said that you said women like
me right yeah I'm saying women that are
is argumentative sexually liberated like
those are the kinds of things I wasn't
going women like me on a scale of 1 to
10 what are we rating on a scale of 1 to
10 I don't know I mean I'm asking you
because you said you're the one that
wanted to rate me on rate on a scale of
one to 10 what's the metric you don't
even know the
metric Jasmine yes try to roll with me
here on the show I know you're you know
like a trained lawyer and I know how to
deal with that it's cool seems like you
don't well you said women like me so
that implies that you're putting
yourself in a category women like me so
I'm asking you to Define what the
category is like on a scale of 1 to 10
if you don't rate yourself on a scale of
1 to 10 then what is that category what
is so what are you wanting I I am
genuinely confused when you say women
like me I'm talking about certain traits
and values said women like me yeah women
like me I'm talking about certain values
and traits that I have you're telling me
to rate some something on a scale of 1
to 10 what am I rating on a scale of 1
to 10 I don't know you said women like
me so I'm trying to get clarity for
myself and for my audience watching
right
now I'm not talking about a scale of one
to 10 when okay so women like you like
what category that are pretty sexually
liberated sexually open um on only fans
uh pretty liberal Highly Educated those
are the kinds of things that are women
like me okay not one to 10 6.33 72 like
what the [__]
okay sure 6.3 772 got it I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out